so what's our plan
leave it to disney to turn something as
boring sounding as investors day
into the content equivalent of christmas
from tv shows new movies
and casting announcements disney
announced a slew of all things marvel to
add even more to the next phase of the
mcu
but what does this all mean for you and
i friends well don't worry we're gonna
break it all down for you right now on
the ketchup
disney dropped an infinity gauntlet size
mic when it revealed huge slates of
content
including everything from lucasfilm to
fx to hulu pixar and marvel
and while we could talk for hours about
the news from disney's investor day
today we're setting our sights on marvel
and three of the bigger stories from the
day
starting with everyone's favorite bad
boy from asgard i'm gonna burn this
place to the ground
fans got their first look at loki the
new disney plus series that promises to
reveal what really happened to mcu's
reformed villain though tom hiddleston's
character died by thanos hand in
infinity war the trickster demigod
managed to escape his fate during the
events of the movie's time heist
when his past self grabbed the tesseract
and transported to places unknown
now the trailer doesn't give much away
besides owen wilson's awesome silver fox
makeover
as a member of the tva which stands for
the time variance authority
a multiverse agency tasked with keeping
marvel's timeline safe
from meddling forces now we don't know
where the tva is located but from the
trailer we're guessing an alternate
dimension where the sky is orange
time moves differently and the identity
of mysterious 1960s plane hijacker d.b
cooper
may have just been solved so look for
loki on a small screen near you in may
of 2021
glorious though captain america has
retired the mantle and shielded the
adventure is far from over in falcon in
the winter soldier
premiering on march 19th on disney plus
anthony mackie and sebastian stan
reprise their avengers roles as sam
wilson and bucky barnes as they fight
some old enemies
like daniel brolz baron zemo as well as
some new faces like john walker aka us
agent played by mcu newcomer wyatt
russell and the team up is promised to
reinvent some of what we know from the
mcu but will they be able to put aside
their differences
to fight international terrorists while
keeping up that witty banter we shall
wait and see
god last but not least disney also
announced that it's going to take
another stab at a fantastic four movie
so far marvel
hasn't had much luck at getting reed
richards and his crew into the same hall
of fame as the avengers or x-men despite
two different takes on the story in the
last decade but you know who else needed
three big screen tries before making
their crossover into the mcu
that's right peter parker which is why
john watts director of spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
will be heading up the new film and our
spidey senses are just tingling
and now that the fab 4 will officially
be an mcu property under disney we can
expect johnny storm to be hanging with
hawkeye in
no time i mean who knows maybe the hulk
and the thing could raid each other's
closets weirder things have happened
i think it's gratuitous but whatever
disney also announced a ton of other
marvel news about black widow
wandavision miss marvel she-hulk
hawkeye moon knight and the first
animated series
what if all right friends it's time for
us to kick it over to you now are you
excited by these announcements are you
overwhelmed let us know all your
thoughts and feelings in the comments
section and also let us know what you
are most looking forward to that's
coming up
in the mcu and don't worry we do have
some more disney updates for you as far
as star wars and pixar coming very soon
so stay tuned for that
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show please hit
that subscribe button and notification
bell
and as always can't thank you enough for
watching the ketchup my name is as perez
and we'll see you
next time bye
you